hello film independent spirit awards
thank you for having me at this event
i'm so excited and honored to be
recognizing these next honorees
who are receiving the brand new
officially inaugural award
devoted to the cast of a new scripted
series
in a world where television has never
been more populated with exceptional
casts
this year one ensemble and the
collective depths they plunged to bring
us their stories took television to a
new level
there is no show that is more deserving
of this honor
than i may destroy you it is rare that a
show comes along that is so perfectly
conceived across all aspects of its
world
and where the fearlessness of its
creator and leader was matched by
every department especially its cast
audiences were stunned and galvanized by
the work from these actors
who with their performances drew us into
this world and gave us perspective so
rarely seen on our screens
they gave us a furious kaleidoscope of
laughter tears
rage shame vulnerability friendship
courage
naked humanity while each being at times
a hero and a villain in their own
stories
while arabella is seared into all of our
souls she was not alone
each character around her was afforded
and performed with the same dizzying
level of complexity as their lead
the best ensemble cast in a new scripted
series is the
unforgettable cast of i may destroy you
all of my roles are somehow interlinked
they don't feel separate
how did you get that i love to
collaborate i love seeing
the results of the writing i'll just
smash your phone
i don't know
[Music]
it's been the favorite moment of my life
[Music]
back in the room michaela has painted a
picture
of black london life that has never been
painted before
sex with men is not safe for me right
now after being sexually assaulted by
one of them
so i'd like to have sex with a female
a female trauma can shrink you or
change you it can stretch you but it can
also bring
different versions of yourself out he
made a mistake nobody gives a [ __ ]
that's a mistake terry we all make those
do we make deceitful destructive
narcissistic
sick inconsiderate mistakes
no if i could convey to people watching
that they're not alone and they should
be kind to themselves
that would be a dream come true
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations to the winners of the
first ever spirit award for best
ensemble cast and a new scripted series
michaela cole papa essidu hueroche opia
and stephen white
thank you to the independent spirit
awards for acknowledging the incredible
cast of i may destroy you
i firstly want to acknowledge julie
harkin our fantastic casting director
for bringing this team together such an
incredible
ensemble to be a part of so i've got to
say that this award gets shared with
every single one of them so shout out
karen
shout out harriet shout out pearl and
all the rest of them
i realized that this project had a lot
of giving actors
who were very giving of themselves to
these characters to the stories and to
the truth
of these characters and stories and i
guess that's what we all
ended up and saw on screen it's a double
honor really because to receive it for
my role in i may destroy you and as
ensemble casts working with
uh the wonderful papa were shay and of
course the amazingly talented michaela
um it feels extra special i felt nothing
but encouragement
and support from my wonderful humble
cast
who brought these characters to life in
a way that i never imagined possible
the biggest privilege of always being
able to share this one with
all of them so thank you so much thank
you
stay safe stay sane and i'll see you all
on santa monica beach i'm probably
running around like a lunatic waving
this in the air
we brought the a game and here it is
thank you so much and congratulations
you deserve this
this
you